hey everybody mr kobe here
so this is a little test of
a solution called
benedict solution and benedict's
solution you can see from the color
of the bottle the liquid through the
bottle benedict's solution has a natural
bluish color to it and you can see i've
already added
some benedict solution into these test
tubes
put it against a white background and
you can see
benedict's solution has a natural blue
color to it
now what i'm going to do in a moment in
a few moments i'm going to put the
camera down
and i'll do this and then i'll come back
but i'm going to add
a milliliter of each of these solutions
into the appropriate test tube so in the
test tube a
i've already got
some benedict solution in there but in a
moment i'm going to
add a milliliter of just water into this
test tube
okay and then i will take my
test tube that's labeled apple juice and
i'll add a milliliter of apple juice
to mix with the benedict solution
and then solution c is going to be cola
so i'll take my test tube that's been
labeled cola it's got some benedict
solution in it already and i'll add a
milliliter of cola to it
and then i'll take my fourth test tube
and you can see it's already got some
benedict solution in it
but i'm going to add a milliliter of
diet cola
and then i'll go to my fifth test tube
again you can see it already has
benedict solution in it
and i will add a milliliter of lemon
lime
sports drink okay a couple more to go
then i'll take my next test tube and i
will add
a milliliter of skim milk skin is
skim milk is fat free milk
and then i'll take my other test tube
that's been labeled plain yogurt plain
greek yogurt
and i will add some add a milliliter of
plain greek yogurt into that test tube
and here's the last one test tube h
so this is a light yogurt so
light typically means less calories so
light
vanilla yogurt and i will add a
milliliter into that test tube
and so when i add the
solutions here a b c d e f g
and h into the appropriate test tubes
this is going to allow me to test for
the presence of sugar because benedict's
solution
will change depending upon the amount of
sugar present here's a little
table here if there is no sugar present
then the benedict solution will stay
blue if there's just a little bit of
sugar
present then the benedict solution will
turn the app will turn green excuse me
green
if there's a low level of sugar it'll
turn yellow if there's a medium level of
sugar it'll turn orange and if there's a
high level of sugar it'll turn red
so we can see which of these
items here water apple juice cola
diet cola lemon lime sports drink
fat free skim milk plain greek yogurt
and light vanilla vanilla yogurt we can
see which of these has the higher
sugar contents so after i add a
milliliter of each into the test tubes
i am then going to take my test tubes
and i will place them
into this warm water bath right here the
warm water will speed up the chemical
reaction
involving the benedict solution so i
don't have to wait all day i can
put it in the warm water for maybe about
five or ten minutes and then come and
check the results
so i'm going to put the camera down in a
moment
and i'm going to add one milliliter of
each
into the appropriate test tubes i'll be
back
in a moment
okay everybody so i went ahead and added
a milliliter of each of the
a b c d e g solutions into the
appropriate test tubes
and just so you can see before i start
here is the one where i added
a milliliter of water into the already
amount of bromothymol blue i'm sorry not
bromoblue
benedict's solution and you can see it
still has a blue color now there's no
reaction yet
i'm just showing you how it looks before
the reaction really starts
here is the apple juice again the blue
of the apple juice i'm sorry the blue of
the benedict solution
is kind of mixed with the uh the you
know like i guess the orangish color of
apple juice or the tannish color of
apple juice and so it kind of has this
um
bluish greenish color to it right now
again there's there hasn't really been a
reaction yet
but i'm just showing you before i put it
in the water the hot water bath
uh what it looks like so again benedict
solution is a blue color
this is the test tube that has cola in
it and you can see the again the
brownness of
the cola plus the bluishness
of the benedict solution kind of has a
almost a how do i describe a turquoise
color to it
a little darker blue
same with the diet the diet cola
again the natural brownness of the diet
cola
plus the color the blueness of the
benedict solution
and that's kind of the color that you
see right there would you call it again
like a turquoise-ish color
a darker blue what about the sports
drink
uh so the benedict solution so this is
the sports drink
test tube the benedict solution has the
blue color the sports drink itself kind
of has
you know that lemon-lime yellowish color
to it and so
it still looks pretty blue again there's
no reaction yet i'm just showing you
what the colors look like before the
reaction
takes place once the solution has been
mixed
with the benedict solution so here's the
fat-free skim milk
and again you know milk is cloudy white
and benedict solution is that bluish
color so it's a
cloudy blue color if i kind of put it up
to a window i don't know
i don't think that worked very well but
it's a cloudy bluish color right
now
how about plain greek yogurt so here's
my tested with plain greek yogurt
the benedict solution is blue mixed with
the cloudy whiteness of the plain greek
yogurt
so now i have a cloudy bluish color
similar to the skim milk from a moment
ago
and here's the last one my light yogurt
again the benedict solution is blue the
white cloudiness of the yogurt mixed
with the blueness of the benedict
solution we have a cloudy blue color
right here
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take
these and place them into the warm
water bath so let me go ahead and do
that because the hotness
the temperature of the warm water will
actually help to encourage this chemical
reaction
so there you go you can see that they
are
submerged the tips of the test tubes are
submerged in the
hot water bath and i'm going to let that
sit for
maybe five or ten minutes i'll come back
in a few and show you the results
okay everybody so it's been i don't know
somewhere in the five to ten minute
range i'm going to
turn off my hot water bath here and you
can maybe you can see the color change
already let me take out
the test tube rack and
oh yeah there's definitely some color
changes in some of these test tubes some
more apparent than others let's
come over and take a look
okay so what i said earlier
as i sit down what i said earlier is
benedict's solution is an indicator
it will indicate how much sugar is in a
solution
if there's no sugar present the solution
will stay blue if there's very little
sugar present it'll turn green
if there's a low amount of sugar will
turn yellow a medium amount of sugar
will turn orange
and high amounts of sugar will turn red
so let's actually see what we have here
so the first is just test tube a this is
water and you can see
test tube a water the benedict solution
has remained
blue make that observation in your
in your lab the data table
okay next will be
the apple juice if the color doesn't
show up very well
um it's kind of a cloudy orangish color
if you can see that okay with the white
background of the paper
so the apple juice has gone from the
benedict solution has gone from a blue
color
to kind of a cloudy orangish color make
the observation in your table
how about the co here's the cola
again if it shows up well on the camera
i'm not sure but it's kind of a a soupy
or a cloudy
reddish color so again the
benedict solution changed from a bluish
color
to a red color
what about the diet cola
let's look at the diet cola
so the diet cola um
no real change it's still that that
turquoise-ish color
again remember diet cola has a brownish
color
and so when it mixed with the natural
blue
of the benedict solution it kind of made
this turquoise-ish
little darker color blue here so no real
color change
in the diet cola there
what about the sports drink the lemon
lime
sports drink all right so it also has
kind of like the cola
from a few moments ago it also has a
kind of cloudy reddish color so the
benedict solution mixed with the
sports drink has turned from a bluish
color
to a kind of a cloudy reddish color
make the observation in your lab data
table
what about the skim milk the fat free
skim milk
let me just kind of swirl it up a little
bit
you can see the fat free skim milk um
kind of has a greenish color to it
so again it was kind of a cloudy blue
color
but now it's kind of a cloudy green
color right here the skin milk i hope
that color shows up well on the video
how about the plain greek yogurt let me
swirl it up a little bit again this is
the plain greek yogurt here
um it still has the cloudy blue color
so again the benedict solution started
blue
and we can see it's still a cloudy
bluish color
when mixed with the plain greek yogurt
now what about the light yogurt let me
swirl it up a little bit
um it's kind of got a greenish color a
light greenish color to itself
um and so again this was if you didn't
see the tag a moment ago this was the
light
yogurt and so again it started out kind
of as a cloudy blue color
and now it's kind of a cloudy greenish
color so
there are the samples right there
and let me just leave with
you know highlighting this table again
here
if there's no sugar present then the
color
of benedict solution would stay blue
very low sugar it'll go to green
a little more sugar but still low it'll
go to yellow medium amount of sugar
orange and high amount of sugar red